good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock monday morning it's been a
controversial move but will nhs workers
be able to carry on working without
having a mandatory vaccine murmurs of a
possible decision this morning reversing
the government's position
so what about those who've already lost
their jobs for refusing to get one we'll
talk to the frontline health worker who
challenged the health secretary over it
that's at 9 20 plus with a russian
invasion of ukraine highly likely what
will it take to stop president putin
we'll ask the chief secretary to the
treasury simon clark plus the shadow
attorney general emily thornbury it's
monday the 31st of january
is a u-turn on the cards reports this
morning compulsory vaccines for health
workers could be scrapped because of a
staffing crisis with warnings of a
russian invasion highly likely nato
bolsters operations as the uk prepares
to reveal tougher sanctions against
russia today
two storms have hit scotland in the
north of england over the weekend
thousands of people have been left
without power
the manchester united footballer mason
greenwood remains in police custody
after being arrested on suspicion of
rape and assault
the new warning for women gamblers will
speak to someone who had 76 different
gambling accounts as my director says
absolute banger streaming controversy
spotify agree to content warnings after
joni mitchell adds her voice to a row
over covert vaccine misinformation
whether you're watching us in singapore
or south africa this morning you're very
welcome a new warning on astrazeneca
side effects we'll get the lowdown from
our resident gp droid that's at 8 40.
and feel the rhythm feel the rhyme the
former dj and turn skier remixing the
spirit of cool runnings and preparing
for the winter olympics we'll speak to
benjamin alexander at 8 45.
[Music]
hello everybody how you all feeling
we'll get you through the morning don't
you worry we start this morning with
rumors of a big u-turn it's been
reported that mandatory covered
vaccinations for health care workers
will be scrapped amid warnings of a
severe staffing crisis if the policy
goes ahead the department of health
telling us they don't deny the report
the deadline for nhs staff to have their
second dose is the first of april or
they risk losing their jobs that means
that in order to meet the deadline they
must get their first dose by this
thursday the 3rd of february
77 000 nhs staff in england could be
impacted with women and ethnic
minorities the hardest hit
the policy came into effect for care
workers in november and around 40 000
are thought to have lost their jobs okay
let's talk about it in more detail
should we katie's joining us this
morning with the details hi katie good
morning good morning good morning so
it's not been denied
no it hasn't so uh last night the
government was questioned about this
policy and they did not deny as you say
that it looks like it's going to be
scrapped and it has been i think it's
fair to say pretty
controversial i mean it really would be
a 11th hour u-turn with workers
obviously having to get their first job
uh by the third of february which is
this thursday uh in order to meet that
deadline now it's understood partly this
climb down is because the policy was
brought in when delta was the dominant
variant and said javid last week the
health secretary has said that given
that omicron makes up nearly all cases
now the policy was being kept under
review in light of the fact that omicron
is intrinsically less severe but of
course the main issue really is this
huge fears of a staffing crisis if this
policy was brought in 77 000 nhs workers
thought to be facing the sac because
they didn't want to get those two
vaccines and we've had uh warnings from
the royal college of nursing the royal
college of midwives among others that
this could have a real impact on patient
care if those workers were to lose their
jobs now we've heard from the royal
college of nursing about this uh
potential climb down and they said they
welcomed the decision to scrap the
policy and despite encouraging vaccines
among all their staff they said making
it mandatory was the wrong policy and
would have added to current pressure on
the nhs okay on social care i know
you're going to go out and about and
find out what health workers are
thinking about that so we'll speak to
you in the next hour thanks so much
indeed thanks what about the papers
what do they think about it quick look
at some of the front pages this morning
for us boris johnson is preparing a
blitz of policy announcements which he
hopes will capture the news headlines
this week according to the eye but the
paper says it won't be enough to drown
out the noise from the ongoing partygate
scandal
meanwhile the met tro uh the metro i'll
say that again splashes on the backlash
uh from tory backbenches over the 12
billion pounds hike in the national
insurance which is set to go ahead lots
to talk to the minister about isn't that
simon clark whose sexually the treasury
is with us good morning good morning
thank you so much for joining us on the
program this morning let's start with
those covered jabs are they going to be
scrapped well this is a policy that
we've always kept under review and we've
been trying to strike throughout this
pandemic the right balance between
having the the maximum impact in terms
of measures that support public safety
in the face of the virus but also have
the minimum impact in terms of our wider
freedoms as a society and it's in that
context that the decision was made last
autumn to make sure that we uh went went
ahead with the manchester vaccination
policy and that was because obviously we
had the delta variant extremely
dangerous uh taking a huge toll on our
society and we wanted to make sure that
people going into hospital very
vulnerable people whether they had
covered or another condition which
required treatment weren't going to be
faced with an increased risk of
infection on the wards
we continue to monitor that situation
very very closely what we know about
emicron is that it is much more
transmissible but less severe
any decision that's taken uh this week
will reflect that reality i i can't
prejudge uh the decision that that is
going to be made but obviously we do
recognize those realities and that does
open a space i just want to play well we
can look at this again for some answer i
want to play you this uh this grab and
see whether this is uh why there was the
change of heart here we go
maybe there's an opportunity to
reconsider with omicron and the changing
picture or at least the nuance it will
allow doctors who've had antibody
exposure
who've got antibodies who haven't had
the vaccination
to not have it
there you go so he was challenged the
health secretary was embarrassed around
80 000 health healthcare workers are
still unvaccinated what's going to
happen to them now
well it has to be seen in in in the
wider context there are 1.2 million
full-time equivalent staff in the nhs
that's actually gone up 45 000 over the
last year so it's a well staffed service
but obviously and it's not much well
it's very short stuff but actually it's
it's it's not it's got 45 000 more
full-time equivalent staff in it than it
had a thousand care staff lost their
jobs because they hadn't been vaccinated
well
look that's separate from the nhs we've
got 45 000 more staff than we had a year
ago 1.2 million in in in total full-time
equivalent and we always want to make
sure those members stayed and lost their
jobs we always want to make sure that
those numbers stay as robust as they uh
can possibly be and that we can provide
the best possible care but we also as i
say have to balance that against the
the reality that if you are not
vaccinated then you do obviously pose
more of a threat both to you yourself
your colleagues and to patients and that
is and that is the stark reality of a
highly transmissible very dangerous
virus that's why we have taken the
measures we have obviously when it comes
to omicron and the fact that the the
virus has mutated we continue to monitor
the impact of of wider policy so what
about those people there's 80 000
healthcare workers who are still waiting
to find out whether they're going to
keep their jobs or not from april what's
going to happen well uh there will be a
decision made in in the in the course of
the next few days and that's that opens
the window as i say for us to look at
this let's talk about national insurance
going up um should we it is going up
according to both the chancellor and the
prime minister they underlined that in
the papers uh yesterday this is what the
prime minister said on the 29th of
november 2019.
read my lips we will not be raising
taxes on income or vat or national
insurance on the contrary what we are
the lifetime of that government for the
lifetime of the of the parliament
well that was
about three months before the
coronavirus pandemic hit which has left
us with this enormous backlog of nhs
treatment i think you know everyone
watching this program will know someone
who's been affected by
uh nhs waiting lists for for key
treatments going up as a result of the
backlogging care flowing from the
pandemic
the nhs
and social care levy that is going to
allow us to do 9 million more scans
checks and operations things which will
bear down on that backlog make sure we
can get back
to normal and also address what we all
know to be a long challenge of an aging
society in terms of a sustainable
solution
[Laughter]
the tory manifesto 2019 we promise not
to raise the rates of income tax
national insurance or vat
this is a tax guarantee that will
protect the incomes of hard-working
families across the next parliament yeah
and look i'm a low-tax conservative i
think everyone who's done on that
manifesto was proud of the fact that we
committed not to uh to raise taxes but
no one could have could have reckoned
with the impact of what we've seen over
the last two years it's been an
extraordinary event we've spent over 400
billion pounds responding to coronavirus
and obviously that's allowed us to both
keep the health service running but also
to introduce things like the furlough
scheme which has saved literally
millions of jobs it's in that context
that we've incurred these huge debts
it's in that context as well that we've
accumulated these nhs backlogs and we
have to be honest with people we can
either pay for more treatments by
whacking up borrowing which is just
taxes deferred for the next generation
or we can deal with it responsibly now
here's a thought why don't we do this
instead why don't we use that 350
million quid a week that we were
promised that would amount to
18.2 billion pounds a year for our
national health service which we heard
so much about during brexit which is 6.2
billion pounds more than what the
national insurance
rise will
i'm not sure if we got a picture of the
bus just to make the point well i mean
as someone who supported brexit i'm
delighted that we're no longer sending
that money to brussels but we were told
that it was going to be useful and and
indeed if you remember theresa may in
2018 specifically did
repurpose the side of the boss yeah and
and that money is now in the nhs this is
the point where the teresa may unleash
a record funding settlement calculation
well no because we've retreat we've got
more of a backhoe in the nhs than anyone
knew but for the 70th anniversary of the
the nhs back in 2018 to the nhs we gave
a record expert we gave up a rep that
you promised on the side of that bus we
gave a funding settlement to the nhs
which was actually larger than that some
and that was theresa may's announcement
back in 2018. okay so the people that
are facing a 10 increase in their
national insurance contributions someone
earning 30 000 pounds will now pay 270
pounds more a year given that the cost
of living is increasing given that the
um the uh
heating the homes is just going to be
almost impossible for so many people
going up perhaps a thousand pounds where
are they going to find the money from
well the cost of living is is a major
issue it's important though to be clear
about what the health and social care
levy will cost the six million lowest
earners won't pay anything extra uh and
50 the top 15 percent of earners will
pay
almost half the cost of the policy so
it's a very progressive policy for for
your average uh for your average uh
taxpayer this is this is a question of
literally uh three or four pounds more
per week in the context of bearing down
on this
huge back cog as i say of accumulated uh
waiting list we have to make sure that
we can fund that sustainably as i said
the only alternative every single penny
will go to the national house
it will yes this is an entirely
dedicated tax for those purposes it goes
it goes nowhere else when you've lied to
us before well uh with respect kay i i i
haven't and no and when i say you i
meant you're representing the government
this morning so collectively i've just
showed you how you did it we we we
didn't lie we we made it economical with
the actuality no we we we made a
commitment in in 2019 that we weren't
going to raise taxes that was before a
global pandemic which has cost hundreds
of thousands of lives it's it's
accumulated a
enormous backlogging care and we have to
make uh responsible decisions i think
you know a conservative government will
always take the fiscally responsible
route and it is simply irresponsible for
us to say we're going to whack all of
this on on our debt when we know that is
already extremely large at a record high
and crucially when a one percent rise in
interest rates would cost us an extra
twenty three billion prime minister
always honest with us he is are you sure
yeah i i absolutely do i'm very proud to
be a member of his government okay so uh
the fact that he has basically said that
he wasn't aware of parties at number 10
it's been proven that not only was he
aware of them but he was also at them
it's also been proven that he uh
misled parliament um let's not over
complicate the matter
uh given what sue gray has what we're
hearing sue gray has been investigating
the police are investigating he should
just resign no well look uh the sue gray
report will come forward soon and
obviously i i don't know exactly when
that's a matter of fault for sugray uh
to decide
uh and and when she does the premise has
been clear he will come to parliament to
make a further uh statement based on all
the facts but look the prime minister is
a good man he's a good leader and i
think
no i think i think it's very important
that we allow an independent act twice
relying i think we once from the uh a
national newspaper and once by michael
howard i think it is absolutely vital we
don't that we don't prejudge what sue
grey is going to say or indeed what the
met police are investigating you said he
doesn't lie and i've made a point i've
just illustrated twice i have total
confidence in the prime minister but you
said he didn't lie i i do not believe
that he does lie okay so why do you
think he was sacked by the times for
lying i i okay i i i i don't know
michael howard for life i don't know the
circumstances absolutely
i don't know the circumstances on three
occasions
previous employment okay that's that's
simply uh michael howard works for the
conservative party look the the
decisions about who was on the shadow
front bench uh
15 years ago uh and and the precise
circumstances which surrounded any if
there were lines that were made 15 years
ago they don't count them okay what i'm
saying is that we've got to wait for a
super reporter okay talk to me about
what's going on as far as russia is
concerned we're told that there'll be
new sanctions
um coming forward quite soon tory party
do you take quite a lot of money
off the russians don't they well any any
any donations which are received by any
politician from any party have to be
from uh uk
uh donors we no no one in in british
politics can take money from
foreign of course
and any such declarations have to be
properly declared on the wider russia
situation it's really important i think
that we're we're clear today it is
obviously very serious and we are uh
keeping a very watchful eye on what's
happening in the ukraine and any
decision by
the russian government to invade would
be a
uh a disastrous act on their part which
would incur the harshest possibility
about the sanctions though
and
the russia report much delayed until
after the last election finally in july
of 2020 the uk welcomed russian money
and few questions if any were asked
about the provenance of the considerable
wealth well the uk is one of the most
robust uh money laundering regimes in
the world we we
and we're one of them
no one has done more to channel the
flood of money out of russia than
london's army of lawyers bankers and
accountants well uh look we obviously
continue to monitor the challenges which
flow from the fact that london is one of
the world's uh primary financial centers
and and obviously that is a challenge as
well as a huge asset to the united
kingdom that we are
such a financial hub when it comes to
the wider impact of
of russian money we continue as i say
always to monitor the situation and we
are very clear that uh if russia takes
further action against ukraine then we
will further tighten the sanctioned
regimes targeting those businesses and
people with the closest links to the
creditors chris johnson um has been very
close to oligarchs in his career 2014 he
um 160 000 donation to the conservative
party by a former russian minister's
wife so that she could play
tennis with him
and david cameron well
anyone who donates to any political
party has to be a uk national that is
that that is that is that is the reality
of of the the laws that we have in place
those laws are scrupulously respected by
the conservative party as indeed uh i
would hope they are by all political
parties let me put this last point to
you if i may and then i must let you go
again from the russia report a member of
the committee that looked into it stuart
hosey said there had been no assessment
of russian interference in the eu
referendum and that goes back to nobody
wanting to touch this issue with a
10-foot poll he said it was astonishing
that the uk government didn't seek to
protect the referendum by looking into
potential interference so you weren't
very interested before brexit why should
why should we believe you know there's
two things to say about that one is that
stuart hosey is an snp mp and we know
the snc's position
well we know the smp's position on
brexit which is obsessionally uh against
the other thing to say is that brexit
brexit britain are you rubbish in the
russian republic brexit britain is one
of the foremost opponents of the actions
of the putin regime if you look at the
eu it is countries like germany who are
dragging their feet when it comes to the
the response to this crisis we are the
ones tightening a sanctioned regime
making sure we support our nato allies
and standing up to putin in a way which
frankly is is leading the continent
rather than following it alok sharma uh
dominic raab rishi sunak uh the prime
minister um brandon lewis all took money
directly from the russians or via their
constituency or by their constituency
offices in order to continue in power
sorry can you say that no no one no one
has taken money from the russians that's
that's but let's be very clear about
this
no no people who are british citizens it
is it is vital we establish distinction
it is simply not true people say that we
have money in in russia russian
oligarchs one needs to be a uk national
a british citizen in order to to make a
donation any such donations are properly
scrutinized and declared as part of any
of those people having links to russia
do you think
okay any look there's nothing there's
nothing there's nothing wrong with any
with any person in business having a
link with what what with any country as
long as it's legally acquired uh wealth
and how they choose to uh how they
choose to spend it at that point is a
matter for them even if it's 160 000
pounds to play tennis boris johnson well
look
look at the situation with barry gardner
and the chinese a few a few weeks ago
yeah
i didn't make it right no no but no but
to be very clear the idea that this is
some sort of unique conservative party
problem it is not there is always a
challenge about making sure that we have
a proper declaration regime in place it
is a problem then no well look to be to
be clear we they were always rightfully
scrutiny on this you accept that the
coffers of the conservative party will
suffer if you bring in new sanctions no
what i would say very clearly is that
there is a need to make sure that all
donations are properly declared that
which which they are there is always a
need to make sure that these things are
properly scrutinized which they can be
but it is also not true to say that this
is russian money these are british
citizens making donations to political
parties of their choice that is their
right i think it is important we don't
muddy the waters on this issue to do so
is to undermine a wider faith in
politics i believe british politics to
be fundamentally clean and i think it is
important we we establish that reality
absolutely it's good to talk to you
suddenly we're out of time thank you
very much indeed for joining us minister
at 9 a.m uh next monday the 7th of
february the education secretary nadim
zahar we will be here to answer all of
your questions you can send them to us
via twitter or email ask the education
secretary at sky dot uk
still to come on the programme before
you have past seven as the wait for sue
gray's downing street parties report
continues we'll explore the legal side
of lockdown breaking with the human
rights barrister adam wagner
[Music]
7 40 we'll be joined by the trainee
nurse who's been reinterpreting some of
history's artistic masterpieces for the
era of covid19
and at 7 45 i'll be speaking to the
former justice secretary david gorg
about what could come of that report by
sue gray on what it could mean for the
prime minister
around 11 000 homes in england and
scotland are still without power after
storm malik brought winds of a hundred
miles an hour over the weekend
and now storm corey is causing more bad
weather there's a yellow weather warning
in place until 10 a.m for parts of the
east coast
standing by for us is james in aberdeen
hi james what's it like up there
yeah it's not bad okay it was a lot
windier last night i can tell you i'm on
the beachfront at aberdeen the sea gives
us a visual representation of how stormy
things are doesn't it we'll take a look
that's that's calm for aberdeen at the
tail end of january i can tell you is
the sun
as the sun says hello beyond the horizon
you can just pick out the lights on the
horizon actually north sea traffic
coming to and from uh the rigs in the
north sea conditions camera for them
this morning i suppose the big question
is what's happening on land we won't get
a full picture of that until
daylight uh there has been damage there
has been disruption the question will be
how many more people are disconnected
how much more travel disruption
disruption on the roads is there
daylight will tell the tale of that but
as you said uh thousands of people
remain without power the trouble is of
course we had two storms in the space of
a short space of time and it's a
question of access access to more than
200 faults on the power network north of
the border they need to be sorted so
that the people who are disconnected can
be reconnected sscn one of those power
suppliers here are saying that could
take until tomorrow to sort that out big
travel disruption as well the rail
services scott rail canceled its
services after 6 p.m last night check
before you go anywhere to see that you
can indeed fulfill your journey this
morning that's the advice k
okay thanks a lot
keep an eye on that for you of course
powerful winter storm pummeled large
parts of the u.s as well have a look at
this more than 1400 flights were
cancelled in the u.s yesterday after the
fierce storm that hit northeastern parts
of the country at least three people
are known to have died and more than a
hundred thousand left without power some
areas saw more than two feet of snowfall
in a single day
nineteen people have been killed by
flooding and landslides in brazil
including nine children heavy rainfall
in the country's largest state sao paulo
has also forced some 500 000 families
from their homes over the weekend
according to local authorities
looking at some of the other stories
making headlines for you on the program
this morning the manchester united
footballer mason greenwood there he is
has been arrested on suspicion of rape
and assault a 20-year-old remains in
police custody it comes after a woman
who alleged incidents of violence posted
on social media
the united arab emirates says it's
intercepted another ballistic missile
fired by houthi rebels from yemen the
israeli president isaac herzog was
making his first visit to the uae at the
time this is the third missile attack to
target the uae by the houthis this month
more passengers will receive
compensation for delayed domestic
flights under plans announced by the
transport secretary grant shops is
proposing payouts for flights within the
uk which arrive at their destination
more than one hour late
under the plan which is under
consultation passengers would be
entitled to a hundred percent of the
ticket price for a delay of more than
three hours
up to a million women in britain are at
risk of experiencing harm from gambling
according to new research the charity
gamble aware is launching a campaign to
highlight the warning signs of problem
gambling
studies show the number of women using
online gambling is rising faster than
men as emma birchley reports
when lisa won
127 000 pounds at poker 20 years ago it
changed everything but not for the
better
in attempting to relive that moment she
lost half a million pounds and ended up
homeless with her children
but even then it didn't stop every
single day that's all i could think
about morning noon and night was
gambling and it wouldn't matter what you
know where i used to drive for miles to
find different bookmakers where people
didn't know me different casinos i'd go
to horse racing meetings on my own
finally four years ago after spending
her wedding night in a casino in las
vegas lisa decided to go to a gambler's
anonymous meeting one of only two women
in a room of nearly 40 people
but research has revealed that up to a
million women are at risk of harm due to
gambling and now a new campaign is
highlighting the warning signs for free
advice and support to keep your gambling
under control search be gamble aware
it comes as gambling adverts are
increasingly directed towards women a
growing market
almost 6 million women and girls over 16
will have gambled in the past four weeks
the number gambling online has risen by
over the past four years
compared to a 28 increase for men
but two in every five women suffering
high levels of harm may not be getting
help due to stigma or shame
and what starts as entertainment can
quickly become a hidden addiction a lot
of them see what they're doing is quite
an innocent social fun activity and we
need to make sure that they're aware of
managing the amount of time they spend
on it the amount of money and make sure
that they don't hide their gambling from
others the number of women seeking
treatment for gambling has doubled in
the past five years but that's only a
fraction of those in need of help
lisa is doing her bit she's setting up a
women's support group through the
charity bet no more to help others like
her regain control of their lives
emma birchley sky news essex
spotify has been stared into action by
the escalating row over antibac's
content on its platform the streaming
giant says it's working to add advisory
warnings to podcasts that discuss covert
19 following criticism from the likes of
neil young harry and megan notify saying
it's me or him and asked for his music
to be removed but rogan who hails from
the world of martial arts has been quick
to hit back at his critics not literally
insisting that his views have been
misrepresented
i'm not i'm not an anti-vaxx person
right in fact i said i believe they're
safe and i encourage many people to take
them my parents were vaccinated i just
said i don't think that if you're a
young healthy person that you need it
but we think that the real reason
spotify have taken action might be this
james blunt threatening to release new
music on their platform including a
single called you were beautiful
um unless they um uh remove joe rogan
he's very very very funny james blunt
love him
early arrivals to the main press center
at the beijing winter olympics they're
being delighted greeted by ice cream
serving robots
there you go each person pays receives a
qr code that when scanned kickstarts the
robot into action
love that
love it quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
storm corey has gone now leaving it fine
for many but it'll stay quite windy for
a few hours yet it's chilly certainly is
with a frost in parts of the north and
the west wintry showers there are
bringing some icy stretches mainly in
the north
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now it sounds biblical frozen iguanas
falling from the sky what's all that
about
not quite the sky but authorities in
florida have asked residents to look out
for the large reptiles falling from
trees during a recent
cold snap the temperatures in the
sunshine state which are close to zero
can stun the iguanas and cause them to
lose their grip and fall from the trees
good news they usually wake up again
when the sun comes out and their bodies
warm up meantime residents have been
urged to keep an eye out when walking
underneath the trees
i think it's called hibernation isn't it
maybe not oh look at them they're
everywhere
some of the more eye-catching stories
from this morning's papers for you as
well i loved this story this morning
ross has put this together for you ever
wondered what happens to all those
online shopping parcels when you send
them back the mail have taken us inside
a giant warehouse in glasgow for your
unwanted clothes return with teams of
sniffers
and steamers racing against the clock to
get it back on sale it's a practice that
apparently costs seven billion dollars a
year
doing the sniff test we've all done it
we've all done it
what was a bright and crisp uh sunday
for some parts of the country
this is what uh the chancellor rishi
sunak
was doing enjoying a stroll near dining
street with his wife and his dog nova
the reason i wanted to show you this is
because we convinced him on the show to
buy a dog for the kids and named and
shamed him until he did beautiful dog
she is too
and the times delves into the curious
phenomenon of seeing faces that may or
may not be there researchers in the
state say that because of the makeup of
our brains we are more likely to see
male faces in random objects such as a
former us president richard nixon
in that pepper i'm not sure that that's
right actually what do you think it's
usually on a bits of toast as well isn't
it
um i once saw there was a frying pan and
there was a face of grease in it and
somebody had said that it looked like
the face of jesus my headline on my
local paper was out of the frying pan is
this the messiah thank you very much
coming up next what could sue grey's
report mean for the pm we'll talk
lockdown law with barrister adam wagner
stay tuned we covered vaccinations for
healthcare workers will reportedly be
scrapped
the defence secretary heads to hungary
with the government expected to bolster
its offer to nato with a major military
deployment
around 11 000 homes still without power
in england and scotland after storm
malik with weather warnings now in place
for storm corey
the government says the space is open to
take another look at mandatory covered
vaccinations for healthcare workers amid
reports of a big u-turn chief secretary
to the treasury simon clark has told me
that the omicron variant is less severe
and this will inform any decision on
whether to scrap compulsory jabs
well this is a policy that we've always
kept under review and we've been trying
to strike throughout this pandemic the
right balance between having the the
maximum impact in terms of measures that
support public safety in the face of the
virus but also have the minimum impact
in terms of our wider freedoms as a
society and it's in that context the
decision was made last autumn to make
sure that we uh went went ahead with the
the manchester vaccination policy what
we know about emicron is that it is much
more transmissible but less severe any
decision that's taken uh this week will
reflect that reality i i can't prejudge
uh the decision that that is going to be
made but obviously we do recognize those
realities and that does open a space
well we can look at this again
tamara's here it was a bit spicy wasn't
it this morning it was yes so he
wouldn't uh commit to whether the
government is not going to go ahead with
insisting on compulsory vaccinations of
nhs staff that was due to come in on the
1st of april but we understand they are
having a meeting to discuss it and they
may well go ahead with scrapping that of
course mps only voted on it in
mid-december it was very controversial a
lot of mps insisted it should not happen
and they've had a lot of warnings from
the royal college of nurses royal
college of midwives and so on saying
they absolutely support vaccination
vaccination protects you it protects
patients it protects everybody but if
you have to get rid of one in 20 nhs
staff who are not vaccinated that is
going to really compromise patient care
in a way they say could be catastrophic
in some areas like maternity services so
they have been urging the government not
to go ahead there's also a logic reason
as well which is you know if
vaccinations are not going to be
compulsory in the years going forward
could you sack all these people and then
find that they can just come back to
their jobs later so it looks like the
government are now reconsidering simon
clark said it was always going to be
kept under review okay for now tomorrow
thanks tomorrow's take at nine o'clock
of course also talking about um money
from people who formerly lived in russia
being given to the conservative party
and in addition to that talking about
the national insurance
increase as well um meantime the wait
for sue gray's report is beginning to
feel a bit like groundhog day but there
are suggestions that a redacted version
is imminent joined now by adam wagner a
human rights barrister who's represented
people charged with breaking lockdown
rules hi adam it's good to see you um
again we're being told by downing street
this morning that they still don't have
any sign of this report even when they
do get it it's not going to be what sue
gray had originally planned or is it the
met have told her that they want it to
be reined in a bit
does she have to take notice of what
they say
legally she doesn't um at the moment as
far as i understand it there's no
arrests have been made and maybe there
are no arrests made there's no criminal
proceedings afoot these are at the
moment what the met are saying is
this is still in the realm of giving
people fixed penalty notices so you know
60 100 pound
tickets effectively for breaking
lockdown rules which is what the vast
majority of people who were found by the
police to break lockdown rules did so i
don't think there's any legal reason why
so sue green sue gray needs to redact
anything at all there may be a an
agreement between her and the
metropolitan police i i see from the
metropolitan police statements they keep
saying they've been working very closely
with cabinet office so this may well
have all been choreographed but also it
may have just been a sort of
a big mess um that was imposed on sugre
at the last minute which is another way
of interpreting what happened in the
later half of last week
the met have changed their wording from
saying findings could prejudice any
investigation um to um they need to
protect the integrity of the
investigation how significant is that
difference legally
it's a huge difference and one of the
reasons that a lot of lawyers including
me really bristled when they saw that
original statement this could prejudice
and investigate we'd ask sue grey you
know to um to hold back on certain
aspects because it could prejudice in
investigations because prejudice is what
you say when something is potentially um
in its there are proceedings so any
reporting
of uh that those proceedings could end
up being a contempt of court which is a
really serious thing it's a legal matter
and it relates to when somebody's been
arrested and then beyond um charged or
whether where there's a trial and you'll
be well aware okay that you know the
media have to be very careful and people
also on social media have to be very
careful not to um report in a way which
might influence a jury later down the
line or now um and help and prevent a
fair trial taking place but that word
prejudice was actually the wrong word to
use it it seemed because they're they've
not arrested anyone this isn't um any
more serious at the moment than fixed
penalty notices so
they've changed their to this sort of
vague protect the integrity
of the investigation which is i mean i
guess it means we don't want people
seeing the evidence that their
colleagues have given to sue gray before
we interview them in a in a way which
will be compliant with the usual rules
of police investigations but it's um i
thought i think it was potentially an
inappropriate use of that word um and a
sort of a slight um
overuse of the police power um to
influence what was going on
um when i was a young journalist we
always used to be told if in doubt leave
it out or ask the lawyer so let me ask
you what would you be advising sue gray
to do given what the met have been
saying to her
well one thing that i you know know from
my experience in practice is that you
never quite know what's going on behind
the scenes and it's never quite as you
expect
so it may be the the it may be that the
police are considering more serious
offences you know there's there's a
possibility or not a likelihood of um
misconduct in public office which is a
much more serious offense with prisons
prison sentences potentially at the end
of it or um tampering with the evidence
if the you know emails and text messages
were deleted you know perversion of the
cause of justice so that's one
possibility and if that is a possibility
even just to post of a possibility i
would be advising sugray to be very
cautious about what she puts out if the
police have said to her
it's just to fix penalty notices and
bearing in mind that the police had the
opportunity in december to get in in
front of sue gray and if at that point
they'd said look sue hold back we'll do
our investigation first we'll do it all
in a way which is compliant with our
procedures then you can go next and put
your public reports out after we've
considered fixed penalty notices that
would have been um much neater but
instead there's now this real mess where
everybody's waiting for a
constitutionally important report which
will you know which is very politically
important um and the police have sort of
you know quite um you know very late in
the day um rode in on their um horses
and said well we're going to
do it instead so please hold off and i
think it will leave nobody particularly
satisfied for now although in the end we
may find out um what really happened but
it may take a lot longer
um
which leads me to um the lib den leader
ed davey saying it um the day before
yesterday that the mets handling of the
sugree report is undermining public
trust in the police do you agree or to
what extent do you agree
i think that it remains to be seen
because at the moment i i think people
are probably looking at it and just with
confusion you know what is going on we
thought we were the sue gray report was
meant to come out a week ago or 10 days
ago where is it and what's all this
business with the police i think if the
police do a thorough investigation and
come to the right outcome then that will
increase um or at least um not undermine
trust with the police the whole the
whole
reason they've been they're
investigating if you've
heard chris the dick's statement is that
the the offenses themselves that are the
government are being accused of these
officials are being accused of undermine
the legitimacy of the law because
obviously it's the lawmakers themselves
who are potentially breaching the law
that's the whole point of this
investigation so ultimately the
if it's done properly and well it will
restore hopefully trust in public
institutions that they can self-regulate
um well i suppose not self-regulate but
they can be regulated they aren't
outside of the
of the
um control of the usual institutions
that regulate these kind of um these
kind of rules and offenses
so but but at the moment it looks very
messy and it looks like the police are
stuck between a rock and a hard place
because they decided to wait um and now
are sort of halfway behind sue gray and
not really knowing what to do about it
good to talk to you adam thank you
thanks very much i'm sure we'll chat
again during the course of the week
hopefully we'll get that report before
the end of the week thank you
former justice secretary and lawyer
david gork is with us now lots to talk
to you about mr should we just carry on
with that while we're on the subject sue
grey um
report do you think the
metropolitan police given what you've
heard have potentially overstepped
i don't know if they have i mean it's
certainly been the case that
metropolitan police's communications
have been uh flawed i i think that
clearly uh is an issue in terms of you
know they took one position then another
position you know whether they're going
to investigate and now they are
investigating whether there was a need
for a delay in the publication of the
sue gray report in full or not that
position has moved around um where i do
have a sort of degree of sympathy i
think for them is that all these choices
were quite difficult for them
and i suspects where they've got to in
terms of the reason why they've asked
sue gray not to publish all the details
is that if you are doing an
investigation as a police force
and you're interviewing a suspect you
don't necessarily want that suspect to
know all the information that you know
that can make that investigation harder
so i suspect that that is the unstated
reason why the police have asked su grey
to pull some of the details from her
report um but it looks very messy it is
unfortunate for the police but i think i
think we have to judge the police
as as adam wagner your previous speaker
has said i think we need to judge the
police's behavior um you know over time
let's see what happens over the next few
weeks
is that not a sledgehammer to crack or
not though if we're talking about fixed
penalty notices which is not a criminal
record
well this is still a very important
investigation um and yes you're
absolutely right to say um these uh uh
offenses that have pretty minor
punishments
as a matter of law
but clearly this is going to be an
investigation that has a huge amount of
interest in it the public will be very
concerned as to
what conclusions are reached
and therefore you can see why the
metropolitan police might be very
cautious to make sure that they to their
best of their abilities can can get to
the truth
um so yes i take your point at one level
but of course you know this is much more
than the
the fines that may or may not be levied
on particular individuals this will get
to the heart of you know a very big
political issue and about whether there
is a culture of rule breaking inside
downing streets and the culture of
cover-up as well so these are important
matters
um to that end you've written an article
in the new statesman entitled there are
no good reasons for boris johnson to
remain as prime minister it's a bit
harsh
well um i don't like the title but uh
but
what i do in my article in the new
statesman has run through some of the
arguments that you know many of my
former colleagues in the conservative
party are making
as to why the prime minister should stay
you know the argument that well you know
he's not a bank robber or yeah everyone
was breaking the rules and so on yeah
those are these are not good arguments
and if you find yourself making those
points then it's just there's something
sort of fairly serious here and this is
not about as i say you know whether
uh offenses that are treated with you
know relatively minor punishments
within the law were bridged this is and
this is not about a piece of cake
and whether there was a cake or not it
is about whether there was a culture
inside downing street forest johnson's
downing street that took the view that
you know the rules weren't really for
them uh that they were above the rules
that were being imposed on the country
as a whole
and and then questions about what has
been said subsequently where we have
heard you know stories of you know
assurances that there were no parties in
downing street to sort of sensible no
one told me uh that it was a party um
yeah none of those are are particularly
uh good arguments and the issue and i
can fully understand why conservative
mps are waiting for the sue gray report
and maybe they'll then wait for the
police report
i i think that is
understandable at one level um but you
know what we already know does suggest
that the culture inside downing street
was not acceptable at a time when you
know the nation did need to stick to the
rules and our leaders needed to set a
good example uh it is worrying that that
was not happening
um talk to me about national insurance
um
it's going to be very frustrating for
jewelry backbenchers um to have to
swallow an increase in taxation given
that the jury manifesto said that that
was not going to happen um you know many
of them very well how will this be going
down it was a tussle apparently between
the prime minister and the chancellor
and the chancellor won
yes
i think um
you know there certainly is disquiet on
the conservative back benches about the
plan um i i personally don't think it is
by any means a perfect plan for how you
raise the money or precisely where the
money is is is going
um but i i think it is the right thing
that the chancellor won this battle
because had the national insurance
contribution increase
not gone ahead and you know it's still
possible that the prime minister might
change his mind but um assuming that it
doesn't go ahead
it does go ahead i i think that is the
right thing to do because had they
pulled at this stage i think that would
have set
sent a very bad signal to the markets i
think that would have damaged the
credibility of the government in being
able to
ensure that the public finances are on a
sound footing
we are going to have to spend more
taxpayers money
on health and social care over the years
years ahead and that structural change
is going to have to be paid by a
permanent structural change in our tax
system a windfall tax
a temporary tax uh won't pay for a
permanent increase in spending so the
money does have to come from somewhere
and i think there are better ways in
which you can raise the money than
national insurance contributions if
you're raising money on income income
tax is a better tax than national
insurance contributions but the
government having made that announcement
i think it would be very dangerous for
it to back away
because conservative backbenchers are
kicking off and complaining to the prime
minister so if he's had a wobble but
overcome that then i think that is a
good thing and i'm
i think it is right that the chancellor
prevails on this matter
very quickly before i let you go mr
scott were slightly out of time but i
did just want to ask you about uh the
reference that cameron david cameron has
made in the past calling boris johnson a
slippery piglet um it does look as
though you know he is the comeback kid
and he survived again
well his stamina has to be said is
impressive you know he sort of just
keeps on plowing through um look there's
been delays in the inquiries that maybe
that is helping him but yeah in the end
i would hope we would get to the truth
as to what happened
and then there's a question for
conservative mps and the public you know
are we content to have a prime minister
who on the face of it is to take a very
very relaxed view to rules and
restrictions that apply to the country
as a whole
so eloquently i wish i'd written that
down thank you very much indeed mr
thank you thank you
trainee nurse in ireland has put a
creative spin on the pandemic by
painting artistic masterpieces wearing
ppe chloe slevin painted the corona lisa
to raise money for a children's charity
and she's with us now hi chloe
hi how are you
i'm very well i love your fridge how
gorgeous are you talk to me um about
your idea
yeah so i just kind of um
i've been put i've been taking kind of
classic paintings over the last few
years and
putting my own spin on it
kind of uh they're up they're all like
over team pb related
but
i've adapted them to suit our lives now
and it's definitely what my life has
become and over the last few years so
i've sort of had a painting in each year
of my studies so far i'm gonna have to
work on on another one from my final
year but
yeah i've i've sell them all for charity
and i intend to keep doing that really
i love it that's the girl with the pearl
earring i'm guessing um
yeah how many have you done
three now yeah so i've the girl with the
surgical mask and i have the separation
of adam and my most recent one is the
crown lisa and what's going to happen to
them
well the corona lisa um so the other two
have been auctioned off previously
but the current lisa actually does an
auction this morning so that auction
will open at 10 o'clock with herman and
wilkinson auction rooms it's an online
auction and the link can be found on my
twitter that's um at claypalgal
so
even if you just love what your twitter
feed is sorry what's your twitter handle
again sorry it's play pal gal
play pal gal okay and and the auction
opens then fantastic and the money is
going you said to a children's hospital
uh children's hospice yeah so to
laurelyn
it's the only children's hospice in the
republic of ireland
and in studying children's nursing
we've really like we i've learned so
much about laurelyn
and the care that they provide for these
children and their families amazing what
amazing
yeah well you amazing work that you do
and then you do this in your spare time
and then you give the money to a
children's hospice well done you thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us much appreciated thank you
still far too beautiful for my liking
though on a monday morning frankly no
for something you don't often see
outside of a sleepover pillow fighting
here we go the pillow fighting uh
championships
crown that i want to play their first
ever champions in florida over the
weekend with both men
and women's divisions the event took
athletes more used to mixed martial arts
and boxing and handed them a special
pillow to thrash
their opponents with each winner earned
a title belt and 5 000
us dollars that takes you back doesn't
it maybe not
yeah
yeah it's not like greece is it not like
sandra d is it we love it though um
still to come in the next hour we're
going to be speaking to labor asking
them about the suggestion that the
government may be scrapping mandatory
jobs for nhs workers we'll find out what
labour thinks about that in just a few
moments time so stay tuned for more
[Music]